hey what's up guys it's Marcus Brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
tech channel of the week episode the
original touch channel of the week by
mkbhd and tech channel of the week
number eight is Macintosh tips and this
is our channel page right here and being
the tech channel of the week number
eight I'm gonna go ahead and give you
guys a quick tour of their YouTube
channel and I also happen to have a
website that I'll show you in a second
so let's go ahead and up top you'll see
they have a banner and yes they are a
YouTube partner or I say they because
this channel is run by two people
eebee and scooter they team up and form
a number of video reviews and tutorials
that have to do often with the Apple
experience so I'm just gonna go ahead
and run down their channel specs here on
the left hand side they have 1552
subscribers we can get them definitely
way past that 1600 1700 really quick
guys they have a great channel and you
guys know they they have a lot of videos
up if you've seen this before so I'll
keep going they just hit 33,000 channel
views a little over that and you can see
in the channel description McIntosh tips
is devoted to making videos that are
Apple related number one and to help
users have helped Apple users have a
better Mac experience so you'll see the
video featured on their channel is
actually a version of I stick ease of
our stickies they did a a video review
on that which is kind of like a tutorial
and if we scroll down a bit here on the
left hand side they have a they have a
number of contact buttons they do have a
Twitter and I'll go ahead and throw
their Twitter link in the description so
you guys can see that and I do remember
them going live a few times in fact the
first time I found this channel it was
them during the week of streams we're
streaming live and I was in the chat
room and I was like wow what is this
McIntosh tips so I went out and find
that found their channel and it was it
was really a surprise to me how great
these videos were so if we scroll down a
little bit more you will see that they
have
sixty-two videos out which is a good
number of videos and if we go ahead and
click on the most viewed videos section
you will see one of my favorite videos
which I actually did favorite was the
Sony VCR I think it was this one the
Sony DCR unboxing and review video was
it yeah I think it was this video and
basically this video is really really
good they used I believe iMovie and a
number of different things
ScreenFlow for all their videos and they
really get into the editing and they
spend a lot of time with their videos
and they definitely get the best quality
out of their videos as possible so
there's no messing around on this
channel so we'll go back having fifteen
hundred subscribers they're able to
become a YouTube partner and they have
autoplay and everything they have the
YouTube shadows box and all that also
unlike the name suggests they do have a
little more than just Mac os10 tutorials
and reviews although a lot of them are
having to do with Mac OS 10 which I find
helpful a lot of them are actually quite
interesting and now if we go ahead and
look at the the contact us section they
do actually answer most questions if you
go ahead and send them a message they'll
probably answer your question so that's
very helpful and they do have their own
website which allows you to contact them
I'll go up to that and the other tab
here which is Macintosh tips.com with
the Z again and I'll put that in the
description as well so you guys can
check it out
it's a pretty good website very well
laid out looks like it they you know
they put a lot of time into creating it
and I they even got the Google Ads on it
and everything so it works well so going
back to their channel one last thing is
that they have a number of playlists the
first of which is product reviews which
are basically you know they have a lot
of subscribers they have enough
subscribers that companies are willing
to send them products for reviews so
they've picked up a few ranging from
iPhone and iPod and Mac Mac accessories
that you guys can check out product
reviews for that if you have similar
products the next playlist is Macintosh
tips at the Apple Store and I was always
confused about those Apple Store videos
if I bet you if I tried to film myself
in the Apple Store near me they just
kick me out
there's really not that many people in
the Apple store that they wouldn't care
what's going on oh yeah they didn't have
some creative little videos that are
filmed at various Apple stores and the
last of the tutorials which has five
videos is
iLife oh nine tutorials and overviews
now they don't just do our fo9 tutorials
so they bundled the iLife oh nine sweet
tutorials in this one five playlist
little section here so you guys if
you're new to Mac os10 you're definitely
going to want to check out this tutorial
series other than that this is a really
great Channel I'm glad I was able to
find it in the first place and I'm a
proud subscriber of Macintosh tips and
they are a proud subscriber I guess of
mkbhd and you can be of both too so
thanks for watching this tech channel of
the week number eight I believe and I
you can check out their website which is
in the description and their YouTube
channel and other than that that is it
guys so thank you for watching this tech
channel of the week number eight and
have a nice day
peace